I can't wait to abandon my children
that's gonna be the goal of my life hell
yeah I can't wait yeah little Japanese
LeBrons yep yeah that's tight that's why
I mean I don't have any kids yet but
like I just can't wait for the day
[Music]
all right the uh hey since you're moving
to New York you're going to want to know
this New York Governor New York of New
York signed the new bill into law that
bans the sale of dogs cats and rabbits
from stores you can't buy a dog or cat
no more where you get one from a store
you can't buy it from a retail store
only Craigslist now I read about they're
trying to like they're trying to stop
like all the breeding and [__] right
they're trying to stop because they said
that all this all the retail stores that
sell pets are still getting them from
like bad places even though they say it
or not so if they're like oh no we don't
buy from like backyard breeders we buy
from these people they said they're all
lying damn so they're like hey you know
since you guys are all [__] lying now
it's illegal so now is it only adopt at
like shelters shelters or like he said
Craigslist or going straight to a
breeder like actually going to a
breeders yo like like a Petco like a
general manager just going up to like
the hood like hey Dante yeah like what
type of like pit bulls you guys yeah you
hit up your drug dealer you're like hey
man I'm gonna need three cats
you got that Palm I want that Russian
dwarf three hamsters that's wild to
think that even it's such a large
Metropolitan City like that something
like that would happen yeah and it is
kind of unfair a little bit to some uh
there are some pet stores that have
never had a single violation of any type
and they are sourcing their pets from
like ethically sourced pets and then
they're like what the [__] man like we
have a perfect record and we're getting
slammed too they got free range dogs I
say good you say good tired of pets
future New Yorker that's your opinion
I'm not gonna have a pet no more bro
done with Pat
what happened to you
my life with pets you know I grew up
with with dogs uh I I had girlfriends
who had pets they had to raise their dog
like it's a whole it's a whole I'm done
with like raising animals it is a kid
yeah that's it this is the first time in
my life that I haven't had anything like
that to take care of and I do miss it
but it is free yeah because I could
travel whenever the [__] I wanted
there's a lot of responsibility to take
care like and it's and it's not like my
child and your pet is your pet yo like I
know people have a dog like it's like my
baby it's your dog it's your pet okay
hold on yeah because pissed off your
folks out there you're gonna poke
certain people but I'm letting people
know like yo there's still an animal
it's not a it's not a human being I like
this Chris it's hot and spicy It's Not a
Human Being yo like it's you're not
gonna you're not gonna have to might not
be a human but it might be family I get
it yo I get it like they have emotions
yeah they have more but yeah they do
absolutely yo but I'm gonna have more
responsibility more care for my child my
son my daughter over a dog yeah like why
not okay so I've actually been thinking
[Music]
it'll be survival of the fitness like
half of them will die right away
there's places like that though a bunch
of countries yeah they're like dogs what
can we live together I went to the zoo
like couple weeks ago and I was like is
this okay
yeah she's all holding a giant Slurpee
she's got the [__] monkey backpack
what the [__] it hat in the hippo eyes
she's like is this okay
so I gotta do something I need to buy
a bike right now but it always gives you
that he's weird and I'm like why why why
do we can we but then when you go to the
chimpanzee side it's so fun that it
becomes like I see why we do it when you
see a chimpanzee and he grabs [__]
dirt throws it on his homie and [__]
laughs you're just like oh this is why
we see that's tight that's like having a
Pokemon but just having a dog
[Music]
let me see like a Komodo dragon walking
through like that's pretty tight you
know what I mean but no you're but what
if you had a a really good dog where
you're just like giving it like
different commands and they go bite
somebody for you they protect you it's
probably gonna shed it's probably gonna
have still like dander stuff you know I
mean allergies that's right but see the
key is if you have parents and they stay
put in a place and you leave your dog
with them if you could do that then get
a dog I will consider a pet turtle it's
not getting a dog that's getting your
parents
yeah abandoned and you borrow it when
you want to and then you bring it back
when you borrow it when you want to oh
that's nice yeah yeah that's the key to
life same with children you could
probably pop out a kid or two if you had
parents and just leave them no my mom no
no my mom said I am no no no
popped out she's like I am not your
babysitter
she's like I'm starting my life now oh
and I appreciate that I was like you
know what I respect that you you we all
deserve to be free yeah you don't [__]
out hers you're like dude kiss me ask
about a grandma and it's just weird that
you're not present I don't know I have a
line of women in my family that are
willing to take care of my children and
adopt them a line of women I'll just be
like hey who wants to take what's on
Sunday all right all right bye-bye I
have a 80s phone that I use
yeah who wants to take my baby today all
right thank you very much bye bye
wow I can't wait I'm already making
plans who's in this line of women yeah I
can't wait to abandon my children that's
gonna be the goal of my life hell yeah I
can't wait no Japanese LeBron yep yeah
that's tight that's why I mean I don't
have any kids yet but I just can't wait
for the day that's like you're going to
Harry Potter School this one's gonna
stay with Grandma like spread them out
yeah and then this is how you get your
kids to love you is you deprive them and
then they go where's when's daddy gonna
come home and I come home and they're
like I love you so much Daddy I'm like I
know you do but don't get too
comfortable because when they're too
comfortable that's when they don't
[__] listen to you you see that's the
key to life
what if you're not around again
that sounds like issues
so tell me about your relationship with
your father
[Laughter]
the old white man came out
yeah Long Island psychiatrists
I'm sitting a little bit of trauma here
something didn't go quite right
you're not supposed to do that these are
not normal baby
[Laughter]
yeah I was almost up by the way
you want to play strawberry sandwich I
got an extra pastrami sandwich I could
cut this in half it turned Italian for
that moment
tell me about to fall though it's so
[__] weird we're seeing a little bit
of an abandonment with you
dude
oh [__] it's called modern parenting oh
that's modern that's very modern
that sounds ancient is it modern modern
future issues pet fishes pet turtles
that's cool
so I have a pet story to stay on track
there you go so let's that's cute we're
gonna stay on track yeah let's let's
stay on track today Andrew Bart's not
here but so my sister she has two kids
right she gets them little hamsters she
gets a girl hamster for her girl a boy
hamster for her boy so cute and then
they start [__] yeah they're actually
brother and sister she like got them
together and then they're like the real
you put them in a cage boom girl gets
pregnant
she calls me she's like I don't know
what to do the hamster's pregnant and
I'm like okay just like look up what to
do and so she had to separate them the
mom had the babies we had to get the dad
out of the the dad will eat the kids
yeah if he stays in there so she
separated them mom raised the babies
it's going super well all the babies are
healthy they're good but you're only
supposed to keep them in there with the
mom for two weeks you got to keep them
in there long enough where the mom can
nurture them but then you gotta separate
the boys and the girls again eating each
other again yeah so the babies eat each
other yeah or no
then we'll kill her babies so they're
[__] up houses reconed themselves too
much so she she separated it was two
weeks with the mom the babies then she
separates the boys and the girls
hamsters
so we got like 12 cages two more
hamsters in there have babies she has
right now she has about 24 hamsters at
her house right now and she has no clue
what to do with them and she tried going
to the pet stores she doesn't want to
let them outside that's she feels like
super bad all she gotta do is get one
snake she called yeah
damn one snake
she called all the kids like school like
all their friends like hey do you guys
want hamsters no one wants them she
thought about that though she put them
up on Facebook Marketplace like anyone
want a hamster but some lady was like
I'll take them all and my sister's like
you're gonna you're gonna feed them to
your snake and the lady's like no I'm
not and my sister's like show me proof
and she's like no give me the hamsters
and then how do you show proof of that I
don't know she goes look at the snake
cage no snake
do you see a snake I don't give me the
answer give him
give me a 24 handy we're going to New
York I can't listen man I'm leaving with
some Hammy
[Applause]
you want some pastrami sandwich
same character tell us about your father
bring it right back he's just in the
session he gets on the phone to have
that conversation
if anybody got one snake
I'm so surprised they just be [__]
ancestral and they don't have any
problems yeah we should live like that
right is that what you're trying to say
no I had that problem I have I had
hamsters when I was a kid and it was the
same thing boy girl I thought it was
brother and sister like oh they would
never multiply multiply multiplied they
got social distinction for that kind of
stuff
and then uh uh they're humpsters and
then um
they uh I had to say they were kittens
too like I had had a cat and she had
baby hamsters and I'm kidding I was like
cool they had a like hello kittens too
same thing like because we we had like
uh like you know got a stray cat and
then that that cat was just though still
getting around like getting getting it
you know somehow yeah eating it and then
they ended up having kittens and [__]
and then we had that problem like Okay
who wants kittens and who wants to yes
you had a whole Farm yeah man I wonder
why you don't want pets anymore it all
circles back we figured out what
happened you got breathing trauma my
last relationship she had a big ass
[__] wolf dog and then she had a
snake and then we had a pet cat and then
I had a Chihuahua and then uh we we
ended up adopting a a pig I'm surprised
none of them hate each other yeah time
the [__] out yeah
Pig yeah how did that make sense with
the wolf dog and the snake we were
convinced we were convinced that this
this it was a it was a mini pig like a
miniature pig which don't exist by the
way it was just a baby it's just a baby
pig oh you thought it was gonna stay
outside yeah and I was like oh that's
tight yo like I would have a little
Pokemon a little slow poke you know what
I'm saying right right right they grow
up bro they did they bro this pig like
in like two three months yo this pig
would end up being like already like
150. and you kept it inside yeah yeah
where did you live we had we're in
Monrovia so we had can you potty train
the pigs can you potty train apparently
they're supposed to be like you know
like once you once they have like one
place where they pissing [__] like it's
gonna be that spot not true that's not
[__] everywhere no yeah yo and and then
they they they squeal they squeal loud
as [__] my sister had a did the same
thing my sister my sister has animal
problems clearly from these stories
um but she got a miniature pig as well
it was so cute little the black piggy
but it started eating the drywall oh no
like she kept it in the base and then it
was like small and it was so cute and I
had so much fun with it but it just
started it was time to go when you had
the Pig when she had to pick you guys
just like avoid bacon because that'd be
[__] up right I ain't gonna lie yo
this pig had a fat ass I was like every
time would walk away I was like I'm
gonna pork chop the [__] out of these
but I didn't do that but we gave it back
we we took the the pig to like a nursery
like a pig Nursery like there's a pig
Nursery yeah I think they're called
Farms called Stater Brothers yeah
Brothers
yeah I'll take care of it right here
[Music]